hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
who won the final presidential debate
and with 11 days until the election
how will it impact an already tightening
race fox news radio's national
correspondent jared halpern
and fox news radio's political analyst
josh crushauer break down the night's
biggest moments
with real clear politics president tom
bevin
judge amy coney barrett is one step
closer to securing a seat on the supreme
court
as republicans on a senate panel
advanced her nomination
with democratic senators boycotting the
proceedings democratic presidential
nominee joe biden now says if elected
he would create a bipartisan commission
to study whether changes
should be made to the supreme court fox
news sunday host chris wallace shares
his insight
on whether mr biden's response will
satisfy voters
recent battleground polls and the debate
over the electoral college
plus commentary from fox nation host
tammy bruce
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm janis dean i'm david asman i'm dana
parino and this
is the fox news rundown
[Music]
friday october 23rd 2020
i'm jared halpern president trump and
former vice president biden make their
final pitch the voters
in the final debate you know they both
sort of scored their points on the two
most important
issues as far as voters are concerned in
this election
i'm chris foster it doesn't look like
anything can stop amy coney barrett's
confirmation to the supreme court
fox news sunday host chris wallace
putting three justices on the supreme
court
will be the most important legacy of
donald trump's first
and possibly only term and i'm tammy
bruce
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
11 days that's all the time that's left
for president trump
and former vice president joe biden to
convince you they are the right man
for the next four years the closing
arguments were made in the second
and final presidential debate a far more
polite and policy driven affair than the
first debate
three weeks ago still the candidates
drew stark distinctions on how to handle
the ongoing coronavirus pandemic
we're about to go into a dark winter a
dark winter
and he has no clear plan and there's no
prospect
that there's going to be a vaccine
available for the majority of the
american people before the middle of
next year
president trump your reaction he says
you have no plan to have a dark winter
and
at all we're opening up our country
we've learned and studied and understand
the disease
which we didn't at the beginning both
candidates previous dealings with
china were an issue as they made the
case over who would be a stronger
economic force
the foreign countries are paying you a
lot russia is paying you a lot
china's painting a lot and your hotels
and all your businesses all around the
country
all around the world and china's
building a new road to a new
a golf course you have overseas so
what's going on here why don't release
your tax return or stop talking about
corruption
and as had been forecasted by the trump
campaign questions were raised about joe
biden's son hunter and reports of his
overseas dealings
accusations answered with questions for
the president about his taxes and
overseas investments
i don't make money from china you do i
don't make money from ukraine
you do i don't make money from russia
you made three and a half million
dollars joe and your son gave you
they even have a statement that we have
to give ten percent
to the big man you're the big man i
think but even before the two men joined
the debate stage with moderator kirsten
welker of nbc news
more than 47 million votes had been cast
with fewer undecided voters two weeks
out than
previous elections that's a pretty good
chunk of the electors
already cast their vote tom bevin is the
co-founder of real clear politics
he joined fox news radio analyst josh
crosar and me for a post of a chat
about the big moments and if they will
move the needle for that shrinking group
of undecided voters so how many of those
folks that are left are in the undecided
are
are actually persuadable and and where
do those folks live do they live in
states like north carolina or
pennsylvania or wisconsin or michigan
where their votes might actually if they
are persuaded might actually matter
probably pretty small but to the extent
that there are those people and and
you know beyond the margins but um you
know i i do think there's still a chance
that i i'm not sure that anything that
happened those
was dramatic enough to move voters in a
real significant way
and so that's what i was going to ask
right obviously there were a lot of
exchanges about the coronavirus there
were exchanges about
energy policy about the relationship
with china
there was a spirited exchange between
the president's tax returns and hunter
biden's
emails any of that moved the needle for
for voters at this stage or maybe of
those issues
what is most likely to move the needle
for voters at this stage
look i thought the president actually
you know
did a pretty good job much better than
he did in the first debate
uh scored points i mean if you if you
think about the two most important
issues in this election are are the
economy number one and covet number two
i thought the president got the better
of biden
feels the economy on opening up the
country
on the issues of energy when he was
talking about you know shutting down the
oil industry that sort of thing
um but the first i don't know 10 or 15
minutes of the debate was spent
on coveted on the handling of the of the
covenant crisis
that is trump's weakest point and i
thought i thought it showed i thought
biden actually had
pretty good responses to trump and so
you know they both sort of scored their
points on the two most important
issues as far as voters are concerned in
this election
and so again i mean it's sort of cliche
but if you're
if you if you treat this as like a
boxing match there were no knockouts you
could score it on points and it was
probably
you know some folks would probably say
maybe trump won it on points by a couple
or maybe some
folks who saved it on points by a couple
but but either way
that's sort of in the eye of the
beholder i don't think there was any any
singular
moment that was really going to be
what's so dramatic that's really going
to influence voters in a significant way
and so i guess to expand on that analogy
the boxing analogy no
no no fighter came out sort of very
bloodied
yeah i mean i think both candidates made
their points
you know biden had a couple moments
where he sort of struggled uh
i think to formulate his answers and and
he was on the defensive but
you know he didn't spend the whole time
on the defensive
you know i was a little bit shocked i
mean i we knew trump was going to raise
the hunter button
scandal issue and and that was
featured in the debate all of the emails
the emails the horrible emails of the
kind of money that you were raking in
you and your family
and joe you were vice president when
some of this was happening
and it should have never happened and i
think you owe an explanation to the
american people
but he didn't go at him he could have
redirected a lot of those questions
back to joe biden on the issue at hand
and at one point you know chris [ __ ] i
thought
you know by and large did a pretty good
job of moderating but she jumped in and
saved button a couple times when
when trump was you know had asked him
hey are you the big guy
you know i think the american people
deserve to know
and and that was the moment where she
sort of jumped in and said look we've
gotta we gotta change subjects and but
never really answered that question
i suspect we're gonna hear more of that
in in the you know final
week and a half of this campaign but but
it didn't play as prominently as i
thought it
would have given how the trump campaign
was talking about it as
leading into this debate tom you
mentioned the pandemic and trump's
uneven
response in that first exchange you know
i was kind of struck that
trump has made some points but he hasn't
really hashed out the argument and
i'm thinking about the issue of schools
and then schools not opening
and trump mentioned andrew cuomo's you
know reaction to the pandemic
if schools are open in new york city i'm
surprised that the president
hasn't drawn a wedge you know with with
and tried to force biden to articulate
what his view would be about opening
schools and
trying to have a path forward on that
front
what was your thought on that exchange
specifically and is that something you
think that republicans could score some
political points on in the future
i mean a little bit but you know the
problem for trump
when he's talking about kova is is he's
almost always on the defensive
and because he's been in office and it's
happened on his watch and like for
better or worse
uh you know the result is we've got 220
000
at americans and he can say and i think
i think there is plenty of evidence to
support that
we've all seen the clips of nancy pelosi
in chinatown in february and bill de
blasio saying ride the subway
democrats were not ahead of the curve on
their handling of this virus and they
just weren't
that is a fact but but biden
you know can sort of just glide by that
and say look i've got a plan
trump hasn't had a plan we've been at
this for six months
so as a result whether the issue is on
schools or on businesses or on whatever
you know trump is is constantly sort of
playing defense
yeah i i i don't want to steal this
question from josh because he wouldn't
have been able to ask it for you because
he brought it up in our conversation
earlier but
this uh this exchange that happened near
the end of the debate tom about
um energy policy about fracking and then
about oil
would it close down or would you close
down the
other way i have a transition from the
oil industry yes
oh transition that is a big statement
because i would stop why would you do
that because
the oil industry pollutes significantly
that is an answer that certainly the
president said was a big moment in this
debate
uh josh has talked about how it could
have some impacts
maybe even down ballot for a lot of
these candidates in key states
like you know pennsylvania ohio uh how
big an issue is that is you sort of look
at the numbers that this issue of of
energy
and fracking versus uh sort of coming
off of some of these uh
fossil fuels to a more uh you know new
cleaner energy
yeah no i mean it's a huge issue and and
look i'm not one of these people i
i think texas will be closer than it was
four years ago but i don't think trump's
gonna lose texas
um but certainly you know john cornyn
probably cracked a smile when he heard
that and some of these other
folks who were running in texas where
the top of the ticket uh where joe biden
talks openly about moving away from oil
and and
transitioning to to you know renewable
energy in the
sort of near future that plays into this
idea that he's behold and he's he's
backing a great new deal
and and he's you know sort of uh
there are radical policies and and
that are in the offing if he's elected
um i think the more
the more urgent uh issue to your point
is
is in pennsylvania and an issue of
tracking i mean and
we've seen that trump folks dial in on
this in a very
sort of specific way right where he was
actually showing
to his to his crowd the other night this
rally in pennsylvania he's showing clips
of biden saying that he was in favor of
banning fracking
um you know to sort of prove the point
that like hey don't take it from me
listen to joe biden's own words
i think that's pretty effective and i
think it could be
i think that's one of the reasons we
we've seen the race in pennsylvania
titan i think it's going to continue to
tighten
and because again at the bottom of the
you know sort of
at the fundamentals the economy is still
the number one issue
across the board doesn't matter what
state you look at naturally any of the
polls
it's so the economy covet is there it's
a number two
in some cases it's a close number two
and health care is a close
you know third um but the economy is
still number one and so
to the extent that trump can leverage
that and exploit that
um it's to his benefit in a lot of these
states particularly
in a place like pennsylvania
hey tom it seems like so many people
have already made up their minds
the people are already voting in fact
over 45 million across the country
do you think that you know this
has an impact in any real way
at the top of the ticker or even down
ballot with some of these big senator
house races
i mean it's hard to say josh you know
this i mean
it's look anybody who's voted early
who's taking advantage of early voting
is most likely somebody who's a
committed voter
if you're really undecided are you going
to run out and vote like the first day
that
you know early voting is an option for
you probably not
so so in that sense while there while
there have been a large number of people
that have already voted early
most of us folks you have to assume are
committed
either democrats or republicans i mean
they were ready to race out and cast
their vote they decided
you know two weeks ago two months ago
two years ago even
but if you are truly undecided if you're
truly sort of
a moderate who's on the fence um yeah
maybe
maybe there are still people out there
that can be persuaded
in the last 10 days of a race and and
they're going to show up on election day
so
and again if if your theory of the case
is that uh the polls are going to close
or that trump's going to over perform
his poll numbers in some of these states
like he did in 2016
and and these races you know in in
places like pennsylvania
and north carolina and you know the six
battleground states we're
currently tracking are going to be close
then yeah it could matter it could
i mean i'd you know not we won't know
the answer to that until
november 3rd or 4th or maybe even longer
than that but
but i i'm not sold on the idea that this
thing is
is so you know the cake is so baked
already that there's no room for
for movement because even on the margins
if it's close
it could matter we will have answers as
you point out tom
very soon now as you listen to this 11
days from
election day tom bevin appreciate the
time as always
to wrap up debate season here in the
2020 cycle
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
we did it we did it
senate judiciary committee chairman
lindsey graham after the vote
recommending judge amy coney barrett's
confirmation to the supreme court
i've been here a while and i've never
seen anyone more
capable than judge barrett on the law
the vote was unanimous 12 nothing
because democrats boycotted
the top senate democrat chuck schumer
the nomination
of amy coney barrett is the most
illegitimate process
i have ever witnessed in the senate and
her potential confirmation
will have dire dire consequences
for the senate for the supreme court
and our entire country for generations
to come
there doesn't appear to be anything
democrats can do about it though
there's political theater here the
democrats not participating
in the in the committee vote and i who
knows what they'll do when it gets to
the
floor of the senate on monday chris
wallace is the host of fox news sunday
we spoke prior to last night's debate
but there's no drama uh the republicans
have the votes
they're going to push her through she'll
be a justice on the court
and let me put this in a little bit of
context there are a lot of people
in the republican side even in the trump
white house
who believe you know forget about the
economy forget about
uh the war on terror and killing al
baghdadi and suleimani
that putting three justices under the
supreme court
will be the most important legacy of
donald trump's first
and possibly only term but of these four
years that
that not only that actually just
re-making
the the judiciary he will have gotten
200 more than 200 of his appointees
uh named to the district court to the
courts of appeal
and to the uh three to the supreme court
uh that that's going to have a huge
legacy i mean amy coney barrett is 48
years old she could be on the court
30 years ruling on cases so this is
going to have
this may be the biggest part of donald
trump's legacy yeah absolutely and this
number could even be low at this point
but
something like a quarter of a quarter of
current appeals court judges now
were put there by president trump in
just the last
you know not even four years and to that
point joe biden has sort of given his
answer about whether he'd be in favor of
adding more justices to the supreme
court and
the federal judiciary says he'd create a
commission to study it he says things
have gotten out of whack is that fair
enough
it's a classic washington answer which
is a non-answer you say i'm going to
appoint a commission
and he says it's going to be blue ribbon
and there'll be republicans on it
there'll be democrats on it
and then they'll let me know uh in 180
days which is six months
so you know what that is all that's
basically saying that's my answer
uh that's the answer for the debate
that's the answer for the last week of
the
of the election of the campaign and you
know
hopefully that'll be good enough uh my
guess is the president
you know is going to continue to hammer
it and say well you don't need a
commission what do you think
and uh and you know there certainly are
plenty
of democrats who ran against biden
including pete butterjudge
who mayor peter was on our show last
sunday who still talks about
reforming the court and adding justices
to the court so
my guess is it'll help biden get through
the final week of the campaign but it
let's let's understand it for what it is
it's a punt yeah i mean the audience
will i hope forgive me if we brought
this up before in this way
but there was a time when you put
somebody on the supreme court and they
lived 10 years now
they're living amy coney barrett could
be on the court for 40 years
and maybe core packing is
the problem with court packing in my
mind is you just every every subsequent
administration can just say okay we're
going to
two four six eight infinity judges maybe
we talk about
making 10 and 20 year appointments i i
have to say
i increasingly agree with exactly that
point
because if you have a court now if amy
coney barrack goes on it'll be
six to three in terms of republican
appointed justices and three democratic
appointed justices
given that uh roberts is kind of a swing
vote it's five and a half to
three and a half but uh you know to so
so
that's nine now if it but saying it's
six now you're gonna need 13 justices so
they're going to need to appoint
four more justices to give the democrats
a majority
that means four more so then you'll have
seven democratic appointed
uh six republican and then exactly as
you say then then
uh when the next republican comes in it
would be 15 justices on the court
it becomes absurd i but i think
your point is i i really kind of think
that may be the answer is it's just too
long
to say i understand the reason for it
which is you know you won't you don't
have anything to worry about you're
going to be in this job for the rest of
your life
you're immune from political pressure
but i think
you know given as you say that you can
live
into your 80s as we saw with ruth bader
ginsburg and stephen breyer's in his 80s
uh another clinton appointed justice i i
i think the idea of 15 20-year terms
in the court which gives you an awful
lot of
job security and and immunity from
political pressure
it to me it makes it more sense and it
doesn't make the appointment of a judge
a huge generational issue
that you know that amy coney barrack is
going to i mean again she could be in
the court in in 2050
right well and just like you said
president trump
randomly getting this power he happens
to have three justices
um on his watch while two died on his
watch
um where some presidents don't get any
it it just seems far too random to me
which justice is dropped dead depending
you know when if there's a democrat or
republican in the white house
yeah i and and you know it and also i
suppose speaks to the issue i i
this might get me in trouble but you
know the times change now i would rather
say this gets me in trouble because
conservatives will say well the times
change for the constitution doesn't
change and the fact that it's 2050
rather than 2020
shouldn't make any difference but the
fact is times do change and maybe
it's not bad to have some people
appointed in
2050 or 2040 rather than have somebody
who's appointed in 2020 to continue on
in the court
i i i the idea of court packing i really
don't like i think i don't stay at nine
that's not a magic number it's been more
and less over the years
but it's been nine for uh since the i
think the 1870s
the idea of a limit on court
tenure uh to me makes sense but it's got
to be a long one it's got to be
i think 15 20 is 10 years would be too
short
okay new fox polls just out showing the
president ahead in ohio now behind in
michigan pennsylvania wisconsin
uh as i think we may have talked about
if you play with the numbers and just
assign certain states to each candidate
it looks like it could be biden by a lot
or the president by a hair that hasn't
changed
yeah and look in any other circumstance
we would be and and i'm not saying that
this is right we would be saying that
that
joe biden not that it's wrapped up it's
never wrapped up until
election day or in this case a week
later uh but
but we would be saying that biden is in
you know a commanding lead we're afraid
to say that because of what
happened in 2016 and i think rightfully
afraid to say it but
i mean if you look at all the objective
metrics
uh at this moment you would say that
i mean biden is leading by eight to 11
points nationally
he's leading in states that if he were
to continue on in those states
he would have a more than 270 electoral
votes
can trump turn around absolutely did he
turn it around in 2016
absolutely but you know there's no uh
contradicting the fact biden is in the
lead right now if president trump loses
the popular vote and wins again
we might see this even greater push to
end the electoral college
the majority of americans don't like it
but that means voters in smaller states
lose their power but i mean
should a vote in wyoming count more than
three times as much as a vote in
california
you know i've gone back and forth on
this i kind of like the electoral
college maybe i'm a traditionalist
about it but i just worry that if
you give it up um and and you know your
your
point i didn't know it was three times
as many but i certainly was aware that a
vote
in in wyoming is worth more
you know than a vote in in another state
just in terms of electoral votes
it's also true in the senate you know
because that's part of what the
constitution did
is it said wyoming has two senators and
so does california
and you know that's why you get this
disparity in electoral votes in
population
but you know it just strikes me if it's
just popular vote
you could see particularly a democratic
candidate simply
go and and campaign in
the big metropolitan centers los angeles
chicago new york you know a few others
and and basically ignore wide swaths of
the country and i think it does
to me anyway it seems good that you know
senators have to take
into account the vote in wisconsin and
iowa and places like that
uh that that you know may obviously
in terms of population uh aren't as big
but have
you know a real role to play and are
crucial in in the electoral vote count i
just think it makes
a president respond to national issues
rather than just
urban uh inner city issues because
that you know that that's where the most
of the votes are
if joe biden wants to get anything done
if he's elected um
he may need the senate um it's looking
increasingly like the senate may turn
blue
any races you're particularly interested
in oh i think a bunch
uh you know i actually i was writing
them down the other day the the races
where
republican incumbents are in real
trouble joni ernst and
in iowa uh steve danes in montana
uh tillis uh susan collins probably in
the most
trouble in maine and you know you've
even got a state like david perdue in
georgia
uh uh lindsey graham and south carolina
those are states you know you haven't
seen a
a democratic senator for a while and uh
and there's a possibility there
this i think really speaks to what's
going to happen
on election day you know both with the
with the early vote and then what
happens with people showing up to vote
in person
is if there's a real blue wave tsunami
as
some people are suggesting and certainly
as you know if you look at the polls
right now seem to indicate
you could really see a lot of senators
republican senators
you know swept out on the other hand you
know if it's more like 2016
will you know the president will do
better than he is right now in a lot of
these
swing states and uh and the republican
senators will do better than they
are right now in in a lot of these
states where you know some of them
aren't swing states and for
senators they're states that you would
expect the republican to be pretty safe
but at least according to the polls
right now isn't chris wallace host of
fox news sunday you've got
two shows left before the election make
them count thank you chris
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
this week's good news comes from
best-selling author brad meltzer i
talked to him recently about one of the
newest books in his ordinary people
change the world
series for kids he told me about one
called i am
anne frank the young jewish girl who
documented her life
while hiding from the nazis for two
years in an attic during world war ii
while researching the history for the
book brad told me he came across
a story that really touched him one of
my favorite stories i found
was when anne frank was hidden in that
attic she had one little window
that she would stare out and out that
window the only view she had was a
chestnut tree
and she'd look at it in the winter and
watch the leaves fall off the leaves
would come back
of course in the spring and that was her
view in 2010 that
that chestnut tree was sadly knocked
down but here's what happened
they took the saplings from that tree
and all the seeds
and they planted them around the world
and today there
are trees and frank trees growing
stronger than ever
all across the globe i don't know a
better way
to teach hope than that and it is just
proof
that when you tell your kids an amazing
story
anne frank's story lives on stronger
than ever those anne frank trees can be
found in arkansas
idaho massachusetts california and
indiana among other places
there's also one on the west front lawn
of the u.s capitol in washington d.c
and one in new york city standing just
feet away from the footprint of the twin
towers
at the 911 memorial in lower manhattan
if your community would like to be
considered for an anne frank garden or a
sapling
go to anne frank.com and to learn more
about brad and his books
go to bradmeltzer.com tanya jay powers
fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
bruce
bruce what's on your mind
the steve scully and jeffrey toobin
scandals appear on the surface to be
quite far apart
about what they represent and mean about
the state of so-called journalism today
but in fact they issue a very similar
warning to everyone the legacy media has
devolved into theater
peopled with corner salesmen who are
rarely what they purport to be
the scully debacle in particular reveals
so much about more than just him
but about the system in general the
scandal began with a now deleted tweet
to trump hater anthony scaramucci which
read
scaramucci should i respond to trump mr
scaramucci is not only opposed to the
president
but gives the impression of being an
active enemy who wishes to ruin mr trump
for those familiar with the twitter
platform that message appeared
to be meant as a private communication
known as a direct message
if one is not paying attention your
intended private message can go
on the public timeline during the
ensuing outrage mr scully insisted his
twitter account had been hacked
that excuse was laughable and yet c-span
reiterated this
and noted they were investigating and
had alerted the fbi
about a week later mr scully admitted
that in fact he lied about his account
being hacked
c-span announced mr scully had been put
on indefinite leave
issuing a statement which read in part
by not being immediately forthcoming to
c-span and the commission about his
tweet
he understands that he made a serious
mistake starting immediately we have
placed steve on administrative leave
after some distance from this episode we
believe in his ability
to continue to contribute to c-span
since the suspension of mr scully the
story is dropped from view
but the other absurdities involved in
this episode speak to the larger ethic
issues
with today's media in his statement mr
scully implies he meant to tweet
mr scaramucci publicly a man who is
hostile to the president
just before mr scully is set to moderate
the debate
that's unbelievable on its face but he
also can't very well admit that it was
supposed to be a secret communication
because that confirms the nature of what
he was doing that alone
is something c-span should be extremely
concerned about
then we have anti-trump pundit jeffrey
toobin
mr tuban a staff writer for 25 years at
the new yorker
as well as cnn's chief legal analyst for
18 years
has been suspended from the magazine for
having
exposed himself during a work zoom call
with new yorker magazine and new york
public radio staff
mr toobin explained that he didn't think
anyone could see
him because he thought he had muted the
video portion of the call
he then apologized to his friends and
family for the obscene display
the new yorker magazine is investigating
the incident and his condi nast email
has been disabled
cnn however is another story it simply
announced that mr tubin
was taking some time off to deal with a
personal matter
no details were provided to the cnn
audience about why its chief legal
analyst was no longer available
on tuesday the network finally provided
more detailed coverage
pointing to mr tubin's excuse that it
was an accident
mr scully and mr tubin have been viewed
as respected trustworthy journalists
over time
mr scully was defended as a fair
reasonable journalist who operates on
dignity and
has a character we can all trust instead
he is someone who appears to have
presented one persona to the public
while working covertly with one of the
worst anti-trump operatives available
mr toobin unhinged in his hostility
toward president trump
is a natural part of the cnn brigade
hammering home
almost every day how awful the president
is morally and otherwise
it's mr trump who can't be trusted who
isn't what he says
who is a bad man who makes a mess of
everything
it's past time mr scully and mr toobin
start looking in the mirror a piece of
advice too
many in the legacy media could benefit
from
this is tammy bruce
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
it's the perino and stir walt i'll tell
you what podcast
dana perino of the five and fox news
political editor chris stirwald to
dissect the ins and outs of national
politics subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
[Music]
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes